since the beginning of civilization
people have known that if you want to
get others attention and if you want to
sort of manipulate them activating this
system is one way to do it but what has
never happened before is we've never had
an interactive system that's constantly
measuring people and optimizing itself
to activate these these old systems in
the human being so what happens is when
the whole society is kind of constantly
being prodded by the algorithms to
excite their fight-or-flight responses
and it's not like anybody at Google or
Facebook sat there and said they wanted
to do this well maybe at Facebook but
certainly not at Google it's just that
the algorithm actually optimized itself
into finding this thing because it's
there waiting to be found by any
adaptive algorithm so then what happens
is you get this diffused version of it
shifting the Society's cognition and the
diffused version I like to call just
irritability and paranoia and so you get
you get this wafting cloud of
irritability and paranoia which then
colors everything and makes people less
sane and less able to deal with reality
than they used to be one of the things
you say drives this and I I think this
is also both correct and profound is the
business models of these companies where
you you have companies that are
essentially profiting off of clicks and
engagement for advertising revenue and
so it's not just that they're tapping
into these parts of our brains that have
been hardwired but then they get
rewarded for it yeah yeah yeah I was
around when that happened and it's it's
really a drag it's sort of a tragedy how
it all unfolded way back in the
beginning there were a few ideas that a
lot of people believed in very intensely
everybody wanted to have perfect
socialism online where there wouldn't be
money and everything would be free
everybody wanted to worship tech
entrepreneurs like Steve Jobs as an
example and and just to resolve those
two things was really hard and the only
solution anyone
found was the advertising model and if
it was just old-fashioned advertising
like on TV it would just it would be no
worse than that was and overall I think
that's done more good than harm although
some people disagree with me but it
wasn't old-fashioned advertising it
turned into this constant measurement
and feedback system this behavior
modification system and that's where we
ran into trouble yeah I think you coined
an acronym around this the the bummer in
which I thought was elaborate out yeah
let's see if I can remember it behavior
of users modified and made into an
empire for rent yeah I thought that was
indeed a bummer that really summed it up
particularly because the Empire that's
being rented or built is being built on
our data like our habits our preferences
what we like what we react to what we
clicked on and you're passionate about
the fact that our data should be ours as
one of the big reforms yeah so this is
something I've been thinking about for
many years and I I'm were convinced than
ever I don't think it's I don't think
it's the only solution we need I don't
think it's like some kind of magic key
to fixing the future but I do think it's
one part of the mix that we definitely
need if you think back on the history of
how people have contributed to
civilization one of the really
interesting high points for me was the
introduction of the idea of quality by
Deming or Six Sigma sometimes it's
called where what you do is you have
people who are working on something
become aware of how what they're doing
is contributing to quality for the
society so that they can take pride on
it instead of being treated like robots
and this is famously how Japan moved
from being a bad manufacturing company
to the best manufacturing company by
making people working on an auto line
for instance aware of how what they did
affected the outcome of the automobile
and listening to them treating them as
human beings but in Silicon Valley we
learned that lesson what we say is when
we get data from people we're gonna
treat it as exhaust that's always the
word oh it's just their exhaust as if
people couldn't contribute and then we
get all this data in that people didn't
know they were contributing and then
we're supposed to make it useful and
algorithms wouldn't it make more sense
wouldn't it be better wouldn't it just
be smarter for people to understand how
their data could be used to be motivated
to earn some money to make it better to
become creative participants to become
to take on some of the power the
decision-making power of what the
ultimate algorithm should do I mean
wouldn't it just make everything better
for this to be more distributed